CHILD SEXUAL ABUSE BY PRIESTS IN
PENNSYLVANIA.
AS HURRICANE DORIAN POUNDS THE
EAST COAST, PRESIDENT TRUMP IS
TAKING A POUNDING IN THE MEDIA
OVER HIS TWEET AFTER THE STORM
HAD TURNED THAT ALABAMA WAS
SUFFER THE STORM'S EFFECTS AND
HIS SUBSEQUENT SHOW AND TELL
DEFENSE OF THAT FORECAST.
LATE THIS AFTERNOON THE
ADMINISTRATION WAS STILL PUSHING
BACK WITH THE PRESIDENT'S
HOMELAND SECURITY ADVISOR SAYING
IN A STATEMENT, HE SHOWED THE
PRESIDENT OF ALL THE ON SUNDAY.
ONES THAT INCLUDED ALABAMA.
TONIGHT, FOX NEWS ANALYST
HOWARD KURTZ SHOWS US THE DOMINO
EFFECT OF REACTION AND
OVERREACTION.
>> THE QUESTION.
HOW DID A BLACK SQUIGGLE ON A
MAP BECOME A BLACK CONTROVERSY
FOR THE MEDIA?
HURRICANE DORIAN MIGHT REACH
ALABAMA CONTRARY TO THE FORECAST
AND THAT ISSUE CAME ROARING BACK
YESTERDAY WHEN VIDEO SHOWED THE
PRESIDENT WITH THE NATIONAL
WEATHER SERVICE MAP FROM THE
29TH WITH THE BLACK LINE TO
INCLUDE A SLICE OF ALABAMA.
>> I DON'T KNOW.
>> A WHITE HOUSE THAT AN
UNIDENTIFIED PERSON IN THE ROOM
OUT OF THE SQUIGGLE AS TRUMP MET
WITH HIS EMERGENCY TEAM.
HE NOW SAYS ALMOST ALL MODELS
PREDICTED IT TO GO TO FLORIDA.
I ACCEPT THE FAKE NEWS
APOLOGIES.
DEKE GOT A "WASHINGTON POST"
REPORT SAYING THAT THE THAT WAS
ILLEGAL.
>> APPARENTLY WITH THE STROKE OF
A SHARKEY, TO REWRITE WEATHER
HISTORY.
>> SOMEBODY DOCTORED THIS MAP
AND THE WHITE HOUSE IS NOT
DENYING IT WAS A PRESIDENT.
>> SOME BLAME MEDIA HOSTILITY
FOR TRUMP.
>> GETS CROSS AND SCRUTINIZED,
UNINFORMED OR A LIAR.
>> OTHERS SAY HE KEEPS
LITIGATING.
>> NONE OF US WOULD BE TALKING
ABOUT HIS SCREWUP TWEET ABOUT
ALABAMA A COUPLE DAYS AGO IF
SOMEBODY HADN'T DRAWN THAT LINE
WITH THE SHARPIE ON THE MAP.
>> TRUMP IS STILL AT IT TWEETING
LATE TODAY FIVE AND 6-YEAR-OLD
FORECAST MAPS.
THE FAKE NEWS DENIES IT.
IT WAS A PERFECT STORM, A
PRESS CORPS ALWAYS ON HIGH ALERT
FOR THE SMALLEST TRUMP MISSTEP